[Music]
oh my god it looks so good this is like
the best cg i've ever seen the hardest
thing to do in cgi these days is motion
i take one look at this boss town robot
i'm like that's so fake i don't think
any vfx shop on the planet could make
this two and a half minute sequence to
the flawless quality that we're seeing
here yeah i just like why do people
think this is fake when our thing is
real
before robots can take over the world
apparently they have to take over the
dance floor first
last year boston dynamics dropped a
video of the robots dancing titled do
you love me i happen to be right there
when it went live and like perfect i'm
gonna leave a comment as quarter crew
you know cgi can't ever beat the real
thing you guys are amazing oh my god 69
000 likes on that comment
are you kidding me and sure enough
thousands of comments are on this video
claiming that this video was cg it
started off well but it started looking
more and more fake we all know it's just
clint again
i don't think corridor is saying it's
real i think they are saying it would
have been better if they just did it for
real this is so obviously cgi the scary
thing is how many people are thinking
this is real
so you know what it's time for us to do
our jobs we're not gonna debunk these
videos we're going to bunk them we're
going to prove that they're real that's
what bunking is town dynamics
people just blanket assume that
something like this is cgi whereas as
cgi artists we're like no that's
definitely real but why do we think it's
real why do we know that this hasn't
been faked let's take a look
oh my god it looks so good this is like
the best cg i've ever seen so the first
thing that's important to establish here
is i can tell that the environment is
real 100 100 percent the way it's
interacting with the lens of the camera
the slight types of aberrations of like
the out-of-focus parts these kind of
lens effects are extremely hard to get
correct and even major films struggle
like lego movies like the first movie to
even get anywhere close to kind of
getting that real feeling and also like
pattern replication is a bit of a
problem in cg because you have like say
some surface imperfections or some like
textures that you want to throw down on
the ground to kind of make it look rough
and used well you only have a texture
that's this big now you gotta tile it
out to cover an entire floor of a
warehouse well when you do that and you
start looking at it from a wide point of
view you can clearly see the tiling and
the pattern repetition what i'm looking
at here is that if someone did try to do
that floor in cg they had to custom make
every single little imperfection in that
floor for the entirety of the floor
every tile is a custom tile but here's
the thing nico i'm not exactly sure
anyone was questioning the reality of
the warehouse you're right that means
that the robot if it's cgi would have to
be composited into real footage that
means we're facing the challenge now of
marrying cgi
to the reality and as anyone who's
married
it's
knows
so we barely have to get into this and i
can already see a couple things first
thing clipping so when you're doing 3d
animation the objects can just pass
through each other it's not a problem
you actually see it in our videos like
there's a couple moments where like the
arm kind of like clips through itself
only because i know it like there's
actually no connection between the
shoulder and the ball it's literally
just the ball and like this thing just
kind of hovering around it that's one of
those things that you just don't really
notice when you're looking at it less on
the robot's joints look at the robot's
feet not once the feet ever clip through
the foam floor to have your keyframes so
perfect that not once in the entire two
and a half minute dance routine because
a toe slightly clip through the floor
which is real by the way because he
established the background would have to
be physically real you're already
setting yourself up for impossibility
you can look at the feet of our robot
you can see how the feet slide a little
bit on the ground you can see how the
toes clip in a little bit when it's
walking forwards this fooled people but
you can already immediately see flaws
when you look for it
to be fair watching it on your phone is
very different than watching it on this
96 inch television yes that's true
sometimes you have some sort of
interaction with the environment that is
just a little too hard to do not just
the interaction but like the shadow the
reflections a lot of the times it's
easier just to replace the entire
background and make the entire shot a cg
shot so that means laying down a mesh
projecting the texture onto it
re-lighting that texture it becomes a
nightmare instantly let's say we were to
do this digitally just looking at a
robot like this with this level of
fidelity there's a few things that go
into it first is the incredible detail
work in the modeling secondly there's a
tremendous amount of detail in the
texturing look at all like the scratches
down at the bottom of the chest on the
inside of the thighs the robot's
reflecting the environment too yeah you
know it's very subtle but it is that's
another thing everything is reflective
even something that doesn't seem
reflective it's this concept called
fresnel basically the angle that you're
looking at something that surface
becomes more and more reflective
depending on the angle that you're
looking at every camera responds to
color and luminance values differently
so when you have a cg render and you
have your footage and you're trying to
bring them together you have to try to
match those as best you can and in this
case we're seeing perfect ratios the
value of the brightness of the
highlights are once again mathematically
perfect on the robots corresponding to
the luminance of how they are in the
actual real footage behind them yes
these are things you can dial in with
lots and lots and lots of work but at
the end of the day it's so perfect
and the color science is so exactly
matched that's really the only way to do
it is to do it for real the thing in
that shot right there that i notice
right away is the shadow of the robot on
the left marrying with the shadow of the
pillar thing about shadows is that it's
just absence of light but the problem
with shadow renders is that now it's an
actual layer that you have to blend with
reality so if it's going to make the
existing real shadow darker it's going
to double up on itself yes yeah so you
have to like do some really complex
compositing to kind of like remove the
part of the shadow that is going to line
up that's doable but in my experience
you end up with like this problem with
the edge it's really hard to kind of
make that blend and there's certain
tools that we use to kind of facilitate
that and make it better but it's a huge
challenge and i'm looking at that i'm
like it's perfect it's perfect there's a
lot of science around how to make
surfaces look good there's a lot of
science around the simulating of light
but the hardest thing to do in cgi these
days is motion the moment you have like
a skeleton and it's moving around you
have a couple different issues you have
to deal with one is you have momentum
and inertia not just in the part that's
moving but the entire system if i throw
my arm forwards and backwards my other
shoulder moves my other arm moves my
head moves there's so much that happens
when movement occurs that it becomes a
incredibly recursive system of
complexity and at some point as an
artist you just cut it off that's the
other reason people do a lot of motion
capture you know you can walk around and
do this you can just capture all that
motion and all those recursive levels of
detail of inertia and momentum and
balance are just happening in real life
so they just obviously motion capture
the robots twitch i'd be like no the
robots do not move the mass and inertia
in the center of gravity of a human
being from a biomechanics standpoint
these robots aren't even the same shape
as humans you see it you're like that's
a human-shaped robot but if you're
actually like measure out the
proportions they're not going to be the
same as a human so the moment you try
attaching
human-sized motion capture to it you're
going to have some problems because
things aren't gonna line up like when he
reaches up like does that with his feet
you know it's like yeah that won't line
up you'll have to go in and retarget
that all manually and then the hand of
the artist gets involved and the moment
an artist starts doing their own
animation is the moment it stops being
physically real to be fair there are
some incredible animators out there who
could do this completely keyframed
because if you think about it the actual
people who designed this robot dance
basically keyframed it they keyframed it
but then that keyframe was ran through
basically an ai there's effectively a
simulated ai version of the robot doing
its moves and then the real really life
robots trying to match those movements
based on the predictions that ai is
making like every time you see somebody
kick spot and it's
like gets its balance there's an ai in
there that's running a simulated version
of that robot and then when it's off
balance that then gets turned into real
life impulses for the motors to then try
to move the legs to the same spot and
hopefully it all works out but it
doesn't as we saw in the parkour video
when the robots biff it
[Laughter]
seeing the failures helps make this even
feel more real it actually has the same
kind of like oh i messed up that we do
you know it's still a very natural
organic reaction of like i'm
flailing so one thing we can do here is
we can see the robot's center of gravity
if we go to where it does a flip and why
are we figuring out the center of
gravity because human beings have one
spot where it is and let's see where it
is in these robots
and it looks like it's just a little bit
behind the h on the side of the body so
kind of down towards the bottom of the
torso but not the very bottom yeah so
human beings the center of gravity is
like right about here whereas the robots
they're certain of gravity is right here
partially because they have a whole big
battery and stuff meaning if this is
motion captured the way it would spin
would not be around the robot center guy
would be around where it would be for
the human who did the shot so in other
words
this isn't motion capture oh yeah one of
the things we're forgetting to mention
is inertia it's basically the resistance
to motion something with a lot of mass
doesn't begin moving very easily it
takes a little bit of like time to
accelerate something that weighs a lot
versus doesn't weigh much at all if
everything falls at a certain rate how
is it that i can drop something from
here and then lower my hand quicker to
grab it before it hits the ground like
watch this ready
you've made your point you may be
playing yes i'm glad you didn't use my
controller that sort of stuff really
matters with the type of animation
you're seeing here and it's the stuff
that they're having to account for in
the actual coding of the motion of these
robots and that's something that anyone
animating something in cg they're just
like
keyframe here move it keyframe there uh
easy ease done
so i guess what i'm saying is we
actually kind of see that jittery motion
that robots have yeah there's like
there's bounce there's vibration like
when the feet hit the ground they go
you know yeah
and it's just not something that we as a
biological human can really replicate
and clint did an excellent job it's hard
to overstate the value of clint's
performance
they trick you with the boston dynamics
it's boss town it looks so realistic we
pulled joel rogan like twice too but
here's the thing we're not that far off
from this thing no okay okay okay let's
let's walk it back lex friedman is the
one of note here because he's like the
big mit ai specialist here and his whole
thing was like okay no no no don't get
ahead of yourself the animation that you
see was done for comedy because it was
it was slapstick and it was clint
expertly pretending to be a robot but
also kind of like showing emotion in the
way he actually moves and there's a lot
of subtleties in how that motion is
accomplished that robots can't yet do
those qualities are like another order
like this here
oh yeah
there's a few things that we are
specifically doing to help us right and
the biggest thing is real-time
interaction it's very intentional that
jake crosses frame between the robot and
the camera and then hands him a gun that
the robot then takes every single time
you see gunfire in this entire video
that is real firearms being fired but in
a separate take with no one around yeah
all safely done and stitched back into
the shot but the dedication to realism
and filming the elements for real is why
people are fooled in this because it's
not just about the cgi robot it's about
everything it's about the interactions
and bees yeah so the bees things
bees the bees thing was added as a clear
like this is fake and it still didn't
work
yeah i just like why do people think
this is fake when our thing is real i
think it comes down to two things one is
the motion being so perfect like they
are perfectly in sync right it feels
like it's animated because it is but
we're seeing it brought to life through
an animatronic the other thing that i
think is triggering us is that large
windows are creating a very nice side
soft light which is like how every cg
render is lit these days with large
freaking soft boxes so it follows the
same lighting convention that we're used
to we have an entire show dedicated to
why visual effects don't feel real
people have no idea why a shot looks
fake they just see it and they're like
that looks off i have no idea why it
just looks off and the reason why people
are looking at this and saying it looks
off is for the wrong reasons
it could just be too that we're so used
to seeing this cool sci-fi stuff in
films i think there are visual effects
houses that are capable of replicating
this level of detail you know but then
it becomes like a multi-dozen person
crew spending a lot of time and
therefore a lot of money to do this i
don't think any vfx shop on the planet
could make this two and a half minute
sequence to the flawless quality that
we're seeing here there's just too many
steps in the chain where artistic
interpretation needs to happen and once
again the moment artistic interpretation
happens is the moment the real science
and physics stop existing and there is
not a single pixel in here that is not
scientifically accurate to what would
actually have been captured if it's
captured for real because
it was all captured for real
all right there's a lot of talk right
now about how hard these robot videos
would be to create and to make them look
real and the nuance with the shadows and
the movement and all the lighting and
everything like that well guess what
courtesy of today's sponsor expressvpn
i'm gonna be making a robot of my own to
show them just how easy it is to make a
real robot video expressvpn is the best
vpn provider out there if you don't know
what a vpn is it provides additional
encryption when your information is out
on the open internet so that it can't be
taken by hackers or used by your
internet provider to be sold to third
parties nobody wants that come on
sam
i am a robot
all right i'm here to tell you about
expressvpn's content on blocking
are you using expressvpn for your
content unblocking content
yes streaming services like netflix have
different shows depending on where
you're located and expressvpn allows you
to change your location in order to
access thousands of new shows that
aren't available in your country no way
yes with servers in over 94 countries
you can get the fastest vpn services out
of any vpn server out there and you can
also get 24 7 customer service if you
ever have a problem robots never sleep
robots never sleep no
sam expressvpn has been rated number one
by a platform such as cnet and tech
radar and you can use expressvpn on any
device
you can use it on your phone
you can use it on your phone while
looking in your smart fridge true
bye-bye robot
bye you see it's really that simple i
don't know what the big deal is i mean i
just made a robot right here you know
pretty much that's how it goes so if you
guys are interested in getting the best
content on blocking and the best data
encryption that money can buy consider
going to expressvpn.com
corridor crew and seeing how you can get
three months free that's expressvpn.com
corridor crew
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p and dot com crew so i
love sitting down and kind of analyzing
actual real-life things and either
debunking them like in the case of ufo
stuff or bunking them like in the case
of boston dynamics if there are any
video clips you guys would like us to
look at and apply that is it visual
effects eye or what would it take for it
to be visual effects please leave a
suggestion down in the comments below
maybe we look at the bigfoot video next
who knows
consider this a bit of an apology to
boston dynamics in the sense that like
sorry for all the hate that you may have
gotten on our behalf hopefully we've
proven that there's no way that what you
guys have posted is fake really what we
just did was a bunch of pre-production
i'm just saying kind of know what we
gotta do now